hey everybody welcome to a little
impromptu nerdwriter QA filmed on my new
fisheye iphone lens attachment which I'm
really excited about I put on Twitter
for questions you guys put a lot of cool
ones in there so let's get right down to
it at Diamond five wants to know what is
your research process like so my
research process has always been the
same and the way that it works is when I
pick a topic and that's a whole nother
story but when I finally choose one I
kind of immerse myself in everything
that I could possibly read about it I
read articles academic journals I got a
log in from a grad school friend of mine
don't tell anybody
and I I read as much as I can about it
until I feel sort of comfortable with
the issue that I know everything and
then I kind of let the structure of what
the video is gonna be bubble up into my
head that's always how it works
eventually I'll get to a point where the
structure of the video essay will just
become apparent I don't know why that is
but it just happens and then I'll start
to write going on from there you know
either I'll write the whole script and
then edit over it or I'll write the
first part of it and think well I have
to edit this to know what comes next
once I edit this first part I'll see
what the rhythm is like and then I can
write the next part of it so it depends
on the topic and it happens in different
ways but the research process is
intensive I only have like a week or a
couple weeks to do the research proper
for videos so I've in heart at Davonte
want to know do you have a preferred
Stanley Kubrick film I'd have to say
2001 a Space Odyssey at the rising tides
wants to know what tips do you have for
people get looking to get into video
essays other than just start so he's
referring to a tweet that I put out
recently where I said that so many
people actually you know message me
everyday to say that they want to get
into this but they don't know where to
start and my advice is the same for
everybody
it's just start and that might sound a
little bit reductive but it's really the
best advice that I could give you know
so many people I know never get past the
idea phase or the conceptualising phase
and what creative work requires is that
you make something fin
[ __ ] identify what you didn't like about
it and approve on it in the next one
YouTube is unique and awesome for that
reason because I get to put a video out
every weekend and every week I look at
it and get a chance to improve a little
bit but if I'd never put something out
there if I had delayed delayed until
still the thing was perfect I never
would have gotten to where I am today
you know the only important thing in the
beginning is that you're confident and
that you put something out there and
then if you know somebody who is trying
to do this that you give them you know
the encouragement to actually start
because that's the hardest part
eventually you can you know give them
constructive criticism when they've
established themselves a little bit but
in the beginning encouragement is key at
NiO T of what Cohn wants to know
expanding beyond nerdwriter what is your
long-term goal that's a good question
right now I love the Internet
I love YouTube and I wouldn't rather be
doing anything else
it's afforded me the opportunity to to
have a career in which my creative
output is 100% mine the editorial
control is 100% mine no one else even
works on the nerdwriter channel and
that's really cool I mean I've talked to
and had you know conference calls about
potential things and other kinds of
media which is exciting but I'm not
totally sure that I want to go those
routes and give up the control that I
have here because that has gotten to me
where got me where I am today and people
like the vlogbrothers who have rejected
opportunities in legacy media is a real
I think they're real pioneers for people
who want to stay online at Mad Mazzella
wants to know how to find ones purpose
in life stick to a thing or keep
searching now this is a huge question
I'm probably not qualified to answer it
but as far as purpose goes I think that
there's a real tragedy there which is
that I think we're obviously not given
any kind of objective or cosmic purpose
I don't believe that I don't believe
that that exists or that you can find
that but I think that even personally
there's nothing that there's no purpose
that you have that you don't choose
that's kind of how it works you have to
choose your purpose and that choice is
it's pretty much arbitrary people who
say that they were born to do this or
born to do that I feel like either
they're they don't know that they're
lying to themselves or there's a little
bit of self too
they're going on and that's really hard
if you come out of college and you don't
know what you want to do and you feel
like I can't figure out what I want to
do nothing is just occurring to me it's
because nothing will occur to you you
just have to choose at Darren Robertson
wants to know I've seen people write off
your videos as pretentious mostly
because of how you speak in them how do
you feel about this I've seen those
comments I probably am pretentious so I
don't really have that much of a
response to that but you know as far as
the way that I talk you know that's just
the way that I talk I never ever tried
to talk a certain way people talk a lot
about the pauses at the end of my videos
you know if you're an editor and you've
edited for a long time you learn to do
things by instinct then as far as those
final you know lines in every video go
that's just the instinct of the rhythm
that I feel works so I always just go by
my editing instinct and you know I pay
more attention to it as more people have
brought it up and try to like make the
pauses a little less but you know I'm
just doing whatever I feel is right it's
all I can do and you know any
accusations of you know a lot of my
favorite creators have been called
pretentious so I'm pretty okay with
being put in that company at Ben Hawk
says what about a video of your
impressions on your trip to France last
summer I can't believe you remember that
I did make a little video about that you
can watch it here at Ryan Spargo writes
what do you think has been the biggest
tool for your growth and outreach social
media award of mouth or your own
marketing the biggest tool for growth
and outreach for me has just been
grinding out the videos pushing through
the times in which nobody was watching
in the beginning and then the plateaus
of not much subscriber growth in the
middle because that that I think will
happen to everybody I try to make my
headlines as good as possible I sort of
hate headlining I hate clickbait I try
to do my best to sort of walk the line
of being not to click Beatty but being
not too boring because the truth is
people look at you know they look at a
million links a day and if you can't
grab them a little bit with your
headline or your thumbnail they're not
going to watch you so I think you have
to be cognizant of that and Hank green
actually wrote a great article on medium
where he talks about how you know you
shouldn't feel bad about clickbait
titles if the content you're giving them
is good work at JD Williams Jay a wants
to know what are some of your favorite
novels I
I have to mention em John Harrison again
I always mentioned he's my favorite
novelist and so so so obscure it's it's
a real tragedy and he's written you know
science fiction and literary fiction but
I suggest you start with the novel light
which is so good and I think you'll go
on to read more of his after you read
that one also I have to mention Lawrence
Tyrell who is who wrote the Alexandria
quartet in the Avignon Quinton I've read
most of what he's written also kind of
Forgotten novelist but his sort of
theories and treatments of personality
and friendship and relationships form
the kind of basis of my philosophy of
relationships and I can't recommend him
enough so check out Lawrence Tyrell
really good stuff at strolling pvp wants
to know which presidential candidate
seems competent this election year I'm
not going to get into who I support
officially but I do really want to
recommend a website called I side with
org in which you are calm in which you
are given questions about a lot of
different issues and and you're you're
lined up with a candidate that most
represents your interests my sister who
took it last week said that everyone
should be required to take this little
survey because I think that's a big
problem with the democracy in our
country is that people don't vote their
interests they don't know you know on a
granular level what candidate supports
what issue on what level and I think
knowing those things would help all of
us and a break through the noise and see
who will actually represent us the way
we want to be represented at the IP
head-to says tips for young writers yes
write more I've written hundreds of
thousands of words since I started
writing them in the beginning it was
crap and I knew it was crap and I hated
it because like Ira Glass once said my
taste was so much better I wanted to be
like the people I loved but I couldn't
achieve it if you write a lot I think
you'll see improvement in your writing
way quicker than you think I mean it's
not going to happen overnight but
improvement happens when you just put
the work in at Paul John can I want to
know would you ever consider touring
slash giving talks to promote your
videos that's actually a great question
because I'm going to be giving my first
TEDx talk in Pennsylvania actually near
my hometown at Lafayette College next
month and I'm really excited about that
I'm going to
talking about video essays and what they
are so I think I will be doing more of
this moving forward and I just want to
make sure that it's great
I want the speeches to be great so I'm
going to be taking a week off I think
this week that you're seeing this to
write that TED talk and make sure that
it's it's really good and up to snuff at
social on let's to know what is your
setup what programs do you use just
quickly I use Final Cut Pro 10 that not
a lot of people hate that program but
Tony Joe and every frame convinced me to
use it and I actually really love it now
and I mean does everything I need it to
do oh and the mic that this is an old
mic and people asked like why is it so
beat up around here it's cuz fault my
desk a bunch of times
it's an old mic from Best Buy I can't
know know if we can get any more but I
really like the quality of it at brawls
E wants to know who is your favorite
youtuber and who you get inspired by the
most so I just I'll put this question
into two parts really quickly first on a
formal level a lot of people loved him
but Casey nice set as a real inspiration
for me because I think he's doing
something that he's dyin earing a style
that is completely unique to online
video that's what I want to see more of
and on a Content level I love the video
essays that box is making right now I
think they're sort of you know the most
prestige video essays from a corporation
that I've seen I love the New York Times
like optics are - also I really love
every frame of painting and Adam West
Brookes video essays at Dell TV I'll put
some more in the description at ELQ
alabaster wants to know do like pancakes
yes obviously Atlanta home H wants to
know what were you doing before YouTube
I might have answered this before but
before directly before I was doing this
full-time was working at discover
discovery digital network producing a
show called secret daily which I wrote
and hosted that was loosely very loosely
based on the nerd writer they got me
from MSNBC and MSNBC got me from a video
that I did a while ago on the kind fund
and before that I was just doing odd
jobs and now a telemarketing for car
warranties which is so horrible and then
before that I was in school so it's been
a wild ride since I graduated and I'm
glad I finally ended up here working for
myself and not in an office because I
hate offices so much at Tilghman trevor
wants to know what do you make of Rotten
Tomatoes effect on
modern-day film culture that's a great
question I you know I always check
Rotten Tomatoes before going to see a
movie just because I don't want to spend
fifteen dollars or $18 with ticket
prices so high on seeing an okay movie
I think the negative side of that is
that we lose the ability to see nuance
in our films and see the great things in
bad movies or see the bad things in good
movies but you know maybe I'll just see
nuance when I can watch it at home at
Lois Saurus one wants to know in your
opinion which is the best YouTube video
you posted
I really like the video I did on Rihanna
and dancehall just because it was a
challenge to figure out how to express
those ideas visually and once I hit on
how to do it I was really excited and
what is the most fun for me is
experimenting with visual styles doing
things that are new innovating always
trying to push the envelope a little bit
to do something that people haven't done
before so that one I really loved I
really loved my actually Death with
Dignity video I did I tried a lot of
interesting things there and anything
that that you see from me that is
experimental just know that I was having
a lot of fun making it at silent but
sure now I want to know if you were a
song what song would you be I hope I'm
day a day in the life by the Beatles
because that's my favorite song and I'd
like to be my favorite song at souza
Eduardo wants to know what's the role of
art in these postmodern filter bubble
internet days and how can we really
connect to each other well that's that I
love the term postmodern filter bubble
internet days it's great for an album or
a book I think you know it's interesting
question because art clearly doesn't
have the weight that it used to have and
there's never going to be I think it
Dickens again but you know I can make
something and the whole world can see it
it might be a little bit more fleeting
then past works past novels or past sort
of mediums but you know it's a it's a
whole new world we have to work with the
times that we have as far as how do we
really connect to each other I mean
you've got to just make friends and be
with people I mean you know Internet is
great and I have a lot of people who I
communicate with you on the Internet and
people communicate with me through my
videos but my actual physical
friendships and relationships are the
most important thing to me in the world
we have to cultivate those I think
because it keeps us grounded and I love
those people I love my friends at Collin
MX 31 wants to know do you work off a
template or have a formula of some sort
no I don't have a template and it would
be no fun for me at all if I did I mean
that's part of the reason why I left
discovery digital networks because the
strictures of producing one video a day
meant that I that everything had to be
templatized the editor has only had a
half a day to work on it so everything
had to look the same every day and we
sort of slotted a script into this
b-roll formula that just wasn't
interesting to me I think every piece of
content has to be matched with the form
that is unique to it at vague solutions
wants to know what's the way to your
heart
um well you should probably ask my
girlfriend about that the amazing
incredible Lissette Padilla who hosts
dnews she is the love of my life I
couldn't possibly love anyone more and
she's talented and beautiful and funny
and weird like me in all those ways so
check out her stuff I'll link it here I
love you
at Citizen Austin one wants to know are
there any films you can consider to be
flawless of two films The Big Lebowski
and Hot Fuzz at Keep Calm
reiden wants to know I read your book
big city and loved it any plans on
writing any more novels so I thank you
for reading big city I sort of cringe
when I read that now I wrote two novels
that and another one which I never put
out which I cringe even more to read but
I you know I love fiction I just think I
love this a little more and I knew that
as I was you know starting this channel
as learning that and I have a third book
that I'm writing now which is hard
sci-fi and it's so cool but I just don't
have the time if you've written a novel
you know that you have to really devote
all your time to it because you have to
sort of stay in the story in your mind I
don't have the time to do that now
hopefully sometime in the future I'd
love for you guys to read it I was
thinking about like putting it out you
know putting it out chapter by chapter
and letting you guys read it what do you
think about that let me know in a
comment a Jay Chou wants to know how do
you feel about internet memes just
quickly I'd like to say that I love
internet memes and that nothing makes me
laugh harder than some of the jokes on
imager I don't know what it is it's like
a whole new form of ultra-aggressive
comedy that has ruined me for a lot of
other kinds of comedy and finally at
Joseph Wallace wants to know what are
the key components of a great video
essay how do you
make people care about something they
didn't know before so this is this is
really my job and I think the most
important thing is that you develop a
narrative about us about a topic about
an issue you know you can present facts
and information but I think people
really latch on to stories and that's
what I try to do with every video you
know this is a there's a metaphor that I
love which is that on film sets when
you're lighting them you know the way
that it looks on the set has nothing you
know doesn't look anything like the way
that looks when you see it on film but
gaffers and directors of photography
know how that sort of weird code of how
to light something on the set to make it
look a certain way you just have to
practice and know it and I think when
I'm doing a video essay on something
what I'm trying to do is kind of create
a kind of all chemical reaction in the
story that I'm telling that makes you as
inspired about this thing as I am like I
said before these are primers and essays
which means they're short so I hope that
I've inspired you enough like the
greatest teachers I've had to go out and
learn more about it
so I think narrative story is the most
important thing getting people engaged
in something that they wouldn't have
thought they could have liked before
okay that was so much fun thank you for
asking your questions I really
appreciated all the questions you put in
there I'm not that great of an
extemporaneous talker the nerd writer is
all about sort of writing and
articulating the way that I feel about
something before presenting it so that's
the way I like to communicate normally
but I think this is a good opportunity
to put put a lot of things on record
about how I feel about stuff and and and
I appreciate your interest always thank
you so much for watching thank you for
continuing to watch I am working my ass
off here to make the best possible
videos for you that I can and and yeah
I'll see you for the next video